so what is the final advice you can give
an entrepreneur that starts a design
sprint the first key benefit of his
prints is the opportunity for everyone
to participate in the design and
decision-making process regardless of
their background a designer or
researcher someone whose user experience
expert will be able to come in as a
leader
they'll be able to create great
prototypes or lead the user testing an
engineer or a product manager or someone
who doesn't have a lot of design
experience will be still able to
participate because they'll have
tremendous ideas as experts and they'll
be able to contribute by learning all
the users want by allowing the whole
team to be involved in the design
process and to make meaningful fast
decisions this printer lines the team
and now they're a real community that it
has a common goal
the second benefit of his parent is the
ability to redefine your town and pull
often large companies and startups are
lacking key resources that they need for
the Sprint because prince short there an
opportunity to invite someone with
meeting Talan for meeting if you don't
have a researcher you can find and hire
someone with some steamed colleague or
an expert in research and they can join
you for two fridays that makes it 3,000
points much larger and third the sprints
have the obvious advantage of key and
feed the ultimate advantage